لو لم يقتلوها في مثل هذا اليوم من العام
الماضي لكانت تمنحنا الان عينيها لنرى ما
تراه وهي ترقب من مشارف قطاع غزه شلال دمن
يستانفون ارقته هناك جريا على ما ضلوا
يفعلون منذ خمس وسبعين سنه تصعيد اسرائيلي
يقابله الفلسطيني
ون شيرين ابو عقله الفلسطينيه التي تمتد
جذور ارتباطها بمسقط راسها القدس كما
بمنبه اسلافها بيت لحم الى زمن مولد السيد
المسيح عيسى بن مريم عليه السلام في هذه
المدينه نفسها قبل اكثر من الفي عام وهم
جدعون وعزراء وبنيامين وبني جفيره اليهود
الاوروبيون والامريكيون والافارقه
والاسيويون الذين جاء ابائهم واجدادهم من
وراء المحيطات غزاه في النصف الاول من
القرن الماضي ليطردوا اصحاب البلاد
الاصليين ويعلنوا قيام دولتهم عليها تماما
في مثل هذه الايام ايضا من عام
1948 من الفلسطينيين من يتمسكوا بمفتاح
بيته الذي هجر منه وحلم العوده يراوده هي
شيرين ابو عاقله الصحفيه التي ما كانت
تملك غير قلمها وصوتها اسلحه دفاع عن
الحقيقه وهم جدعون وعزره وبنيامين جفيره
الجند المدجون لفائض قوه عسكريه طالما
راهنوا عليها لفرض الاسطوره الغابره عن
مرورهم القديم في هذه الارض بديلا من
الواقع الراهن لتجبر اصحابها في تربتها
وتشييدهم معالم الحياه قرب سواحلها وفوق
جدالها على نحو لم ينقطع منذ الوف السنين
هي شيرين ابو عاقله الضحيه النموذج التي
فتح اغتيالها اعين الضمير العالمي على
الظلم الذي لحق بشعب فلسطين كما لم تفتح
من قبل ربما وهم يدعون وعزرا وبنيامين
وبني جفير القتله الذين كانوا يمكن ان
يساقوا الى المحاكم المختصه بالجرائم ضد
الانسانيه لولا انهم وداعيهم في المجتمع
الدولي ما زالوا يستثمرون عقده الذنب
الغربيه نحو ضحايا الفاشيه الاوروبيه من
اليهود ليفرضوا تسامح العالم مع ارتكاب
ابنائهم واحفادهم جريمه مماثله بحق شعب
اخر
في المساحه الضيقه بين خوذه راسها وسترتها
الواقيه من الرصاص اصابتها طلقه احد
الجنود الغزاه تذكرون حين كانت تتجهز
لتصوير هجوم كانوا يستعدون لشنه على بعض
بلادها لا مهنتها حصنتها من القتل غيله
ولا فضيحه قتلها التي هزت العالم غيرت من
بعد شيئا في سلوكهم وصلوا ما درجوا على
فعله كان شيئا لم يكن بل كانهم يمسكون ما
يسمى المجتمع الدولي من اذنه غير ان اهلها
وزملائها في المقابل ومعهم الوف من انصار
العداله في مختلف انحاء العالم لم يياسوه
نقلوا جريمه قتلها الى منابر الاعلام
واروقه الدبلوماسيه ومدين القضاء الدولي
وما زالوا يسورون على ابقاء قضيتها حيه
حتى انصافها من قاتليها
تحل ذكرى شيرين اليوم في لحظه تاريخيه
مشابهه للحظه موتها وتلك ليست صدفه بالطبع
قدر ما هي تعبير عن تكرار ماساوي للقصه
التي نظرت مراسله الجزيره حياتها لترويها
وما تبدونها انهم يواصلون اعمال القتل بلا
هوادا ويواصل ساده العالم تفهم ما يفعلون
بذريعه حق الدفاع عن النفس لا احد في تل
ابيب او في عواصم حلفائها وراء المحيطات
البعيده يقدم تفسيرا لمعنى الدفاع عن
النفس يتعدى اللفظ الاجوف ليعترف ربما بان
قد طفله كهذه في غزه هو اجراء احترازي
مفهوم لمنعها من ان تصبح بعد سنين نسخه من
شيرين